let's go next to the caller from the
three one three area code who's calling
today from three one three I did it my
name is Kevin I'm calling from Detroit
Michigan hey Kevin what's going on how
you doing I'm a really huge fan and it's
a quick question I like to become more
politically informed I find myself and I
try to find out my fingle issues
depending on a website if I kind of
fight us for certain ways okay and I
just trying to figure out a way how do
you become so um politically inform you
know what you do what you seem like this
so uh you look at it from so many
different perspectives and not really
indeed and I want to be more like that
so I was wondering how do you do that
well the most important thing is when
you want to really understand an issue
you're not going to understand it by
reading liberal and conservative opinion
pieces written today right like if you
really want to understand abortion it's
like okay you can go and see what a
liberal blog says and what a
conservative blog says about the latest
Arkansas proposal but to really
understand it you actually want to be
reading the history of the abortion
debate in the United States to kind of
build up the pyramid of the of knowledge
so to speak so the problem that I see
for a lot of people who end up very sort
of uninformed or at least short-sighted
on political issues is that if you
imagine a pyramid the base of them the
pyramid is like knowing how to think
it's critical thinking and its basics of
philosophy then you've got to understand
how government works so it's like basic
civics we're building up this pyramid
then it's particular issues the history
of abortion for example only the very
top of the pyramid it's sort of like the
junk food in the old dietary pyramid
that was floating around the latest news
about X or Y is like the junk food it's
the very thinnest part of the pyramid
and if you skip to that right you're not
really going to know how to even think
about a lot of these issues or
understand how they became political
issues to begin with so I think the
important thing is separate from the
day-to-day news as much as possible and
read about the history of these issues
read about critical thinking and sort of
how to think and epistemology that's the
best advice I can give
thank you ever
appreciate ya you know with my what's my
job I'm actually in a Marine Corps and
I'm also a black man so a lot of times I
get
oh no whatever you whatever you're
saying some super interesting but you
just cut out you said you're a black man
in the Marine Corps and sometimes you
get what you cut out right there I get I
get poured into like a lot of political
debates despite my best efforts to avoid
it I see those debates it sounds like
right I'd you know would lean towards a
left but I just don't want to fight off
CNN or Fox it was definitely not Fox
News but yeah I don't want to start off
too so much headline you know your
instinct is the right one and I would
really try to you know build up the
lower the lower stages of that kind of
knowledge knowledge pyramid Kevin really
appreciate the phone call hope to hear
from you again
yeah okay see you later take care of